welcome my fellow Gods and Monsters as
you can see today we have this amazing
yotna edition of God of War Ragnarok
here to unbox for you guys and if you
didn't already know we really like this
game I really like this game I gave it
10 out of 10. so if you hate me leave
something in the comments below I don't
care but today we're excited to show you
what's inside this Edition so let's get
right to it oh this is a big boy here
which I'll probably need
some help from the key cool boy oh my
God the box there we go look at this
nice little chest here obviously there's
gonna be a lot of moving components so
let's start from the top maybe okay well
I hope I can smash through this like
Kratos does to every chest he finds in
God of War Ragnarok I will not risk this
for this is a precious yodna Edition
instead we're gonna start from the top
oh I'm making this top off
aha some goodies so first of all we have
this
very nice
set of Dice from eccentric Dwarven ankle
Brock so nice pouch here you can roll
them out
and there we go nice top and dice we got
way too many sides on this guys
I have no idea what they're used for but
they look good
mix up we've got a pair of veneer
carving
uh the veneer being so if you had the
2018 Collectors Edition for the first
God of War this is quite similar to what
we had in the terms of broken scenerys
carvings but these are much taller the
very nice details here
so that's what this one
and I think this is what a lot of people
will be coming here for
the very nice steelbook case for God of
War Ragnarok we have that bear and wolf
right at the front who they are I'll
leave you to find out when you play the
game yourself and then some very nice
rune
I would say ruins languages sentences at
the back which I don't know how to read
you know we'll Master it as you play
along and then of course inside we have
the game code which I'm gonna show you
like this
nothing you can't redeem the code it's
mine
so obviously with the God of War
Ragnarok um your night Edition you're
gonna get some nice digital content
which I'll read out right now get a full
game for PS4 and PS5 get a PlayStation
14 and our Bata set a dark horse digital
mini art book official God of War Ragnar
on digital soundtrack as well as a few
x-grips armor handles for Kratos as well
as a ducktail attire for a trace so
you're gonna look good as you Vanquish
all the Gods and Monsters that stand in
your way from the top layer moving on
second layer what do we have here oh
let's get it out for you guys to see
I believe this is the very nice drop
near ring
nice texture on the outside and some
more details on the inside if you can
get it in that red water so
drop near
I can spoil anything for you but it's
quite important in the game so you'll
gotta find out when you play the game so
we got a nice set of
Falcon woof and bear Clips no not Clips
pins so if you didn't know that's why
for you right now Falcon Freya
woof
Kratos bear address and the centerpiece
for the second layer we have this very
nice
cloth map
that is of the world tree I believe a
drizzle
similar to the first cloth mat that you
get in the Collector's Edition for the
2018 Vision as well
I should make a nice companion
map to that
Tada there you go am I holding it upside
down I don't think so
very nice so here you can see the nine
Realms obviously cradles and Traders
will be visiting nine Realms throughout
the adventures where you can expect to
get into a lot of trouble
now speaking of the nine Realms and
before we dive into the main
section of the owner Edition for God of
War Ragnarok let's head to the realm of
good laptops and awesome Tech over at
our friends issues this video is brought
to you by Asus check out the Asus
Zenbook 14x OLED Space Edition
commemorating the 25th anniversary of
the first Asus laptop sent into space
Not only does it offer a space exclusive
design but it's even worthy of going
where no man has gone before with its
space gray durability it even comes with
a 3.5 inch OLED companion Zen Vision
display and you will have a ball of time
taking interviews with a 16 by 10 4K
OLED Nano Edge 10 tone validated 14 inch
display and we're back for the main
event of the yotna Edition so we're
going to open this up to show you guys
what goodies lies inside
ah look at this so this is quite similar
to what you see in the game many of the
prophecies that the Giants have and
painted on the day is nice I guess
tapestries to show you what might happen
in the future uh this looks oddly
familiar but I'm not gonna say anything
about it so let's open this up to see
what's inside
oh very nice but before we go into that
I'm gonna find the secret compartment
here
we will Define the ah what's this
the seven inch vinyl
record for God of War Ragnarok
and obviously the music in the game is
phenomenal it's by the Great Bear
McCreary again
very nice
with those giant hands showing off at
beneath some children in jordanheim
and behind it you got I guess the a side
and the B side you got a side the sun's
puff and then beside the giantess of
Ironwood
shall we take a look at this
the vinyl
do you want to open it up
vinyl
packaging really nice I'm gonna be
carefully getting the vinyl out
if I handle it correctly wrongly please
let me know in the comments below I'm
really afraid
oh look at this
very nice
and if I'm trembling that's cause I'm
scared of dropping it
and now more importantly
that munir replica which will take some
time to put together to show you guys in
its full Glory so give us a moment
okay
there you go this I believe is a 12 inch
replica of mayonnaise you can see the
designs the runes
there is no whoever lives mayonnaise
Woody [ __ ] this is a different kind
of tour that we're talking about so
obviously as you guys have seen in the
trailers craters will be going up
against tall in multiple situations
scenarios and do you get to leave
mayonnaise as part of your Arsenal and
God of War Ragnarok I don't know I'm not
gonna say anything if someone throw this
at you you probably can't catch it but I
wouldn't recommend it
it's made up of
ooh sounds good sounds Hollow but still
quite solid the construction obviously
the details and the handles are really
nice
all the carvings and then the leather
straps and then you move on to the
actual I guess the Mallet itself
the carvings of the runes the Odin has
placed upon neonia
you probably don't want to see this too
much in the game because it's probably
smashed up into your face but as a
collector's edition as a yacht night
Edition I think this is really really
awesome and there you have it everything
you can find in the 379 Singh dollars
worth Yota Edition so obviously if
you're a big fan of God of War
especially the soft reboot in 2018 and
you're looking for the God of War
Ragnarok I believe this Yonder Edition
is a no-brainer you probably can't find
it anywhere now but if you're one of the
lucky ones who have pre-ordered and got
got your order in I think this is gonna
rank you really happy I think in
comparison to one of the other
collectors edition that we covered the
Horizon forbidden West one similarly I
think PlayStation has continued it's
really good form in terms of
presentation with this chest so in my
opinion this is a really good addition
to add to any collection where else
you're going to get this kind of goodie
except from the York Knight Edition for
Golden War Ragnarok thank you once again
for joining me on this Divine journey to
weakness whatever is inside the awesome
yoga Edition and if you haven't already
do check out our video review of God of
War Ragnarok which the links you can
find here there everywhere and if not if
you prefer words you can read our
written review down in the links in the
description below so as usual please
remember to like subscribe and stay
tuned to geek culture gaming for more of
such gaming goodness until then I'm
getting ready to join Kratos and the
Traders back in the nine Realms to
better the Norse gods once more until
the next one
bye